the United Nations is urging Elon Musk
to ensure human rights are Central to
Twitter's management the investors set
off a flurry of changes at the platform
after buying it last week in an open
letter to musk U.N human rights Chief
volka Turk says like all companies
Twitter needs to understand the harms
associated with its platform and take
steps to address them respect for our
shared human rights should set the
guardrails for the platform's use and
evolution musk has ordered the firing of
half of Twitter staff experts are
warning the layoffs could cause a spike
in disinformation across social media
Manuel cornet is a software engineer who
was sacked by Twitter and is now taking
legal action Manor Cornett thank you for
joining us
um not only are you a software engineer
you're also an artist and as I
understand it you think that has
something to do with your firing
yes that's right at this point it's all
uh speculation and thanks for having me
by the way
um the reasons for the firing have been
very unclear have not been stated but I
think my being a bit of a troublemaker
was probably part of it well explain
that a little bit you say Troublemaker
was that related to your art
because the art is uh really cartoons uh
and many of them were
um trying to be critical of the company
sometimes so
um even though I don't think any of them
was really criticizing musk himself
um but by nature or cartoons are a
little bit uh extreme anyway so I don't
think he was seeing that and uh with a
good eye I think some might call them
cheeky
um why then specifically are you are you
suing Twitter on what grounds
uh so the grounds are um from what I
understand obviously I'm not a lawyer
but um
um U.S federal labor laws and I think
also California laws I would I myself am
a bit of a uh too easy going for my own
good and a bit of conflict of her so I
wouldn't have done it by myself but I
have some great colleagues who uh asked
me if I would support and join in so I
obviously was happy to when you refer to
labor laws I take it that you you
believe that Twitter didn't really sort
of give you enough time before firing
you that sort of thing
that's right yeah so again I I don't
know the I don't want to talk about
something I don't know about but I I
think the main the Crux of the issue is
that the uh the amount of time for the
the warning was not was not given you
you know how sort of the you know the
lay of the land at Twitter
um how do you think the company will
function after the layoffs more
specifically what areas of Twitter do
you believe will be uh affected the most
and how might that affect the way that
users interface with Twitter
foreign so I think the constant
moderation might take a hit you might
start seeing some glitches more than
before uh bugs here and there I've also
heard some rumors but these are rumors
that some of the laid-off employees were
starting to be called back because uh I
guess people inside the company were
starting to realize that they may have
been a bit too far gone a bit too far
with the layoffs so it's hard to tell
exactly
um what will happen I I fully trust the
colleagues that are still there that
they'll be doing a good job and doing
their best but I do think it will be a
bit more fragile from now on yes
that is a menu Cornett a software
engineer fired by Twitter now taking
legal action thank you so much for
joining us and particularly for your
perspective
thank you